andrew is in fort collins colorado hi
andrew how are you
doing well thanks for taking my call
guys really appreciate it
sure what's up so
my new family and i are looking to close
on our very first home
at the end of may in nebraska we're
relocating to a more affordable area
and to be closer to in-laws however
we got a call from our realtor yesterday
saying
that the home now has three feet of
flood water in the basement
so what we're trying to do is just get
some perspective like we're trying to
figure out is this
a blessing to say hey you know what
this wasn't meant to be like we should
back out of it we may have to
negotiate with some costs that we talked
about with the seller
prior to moving in you know if we exit
but there may be some homes in the area
it's not as hot of a market as some of
the other areas that we were looking at
or b is this something that you know
it's a chance to renegotiate
the cost with the seller and or is this
just going to be this
a mountain of work ahead of us with
three feet of flood water i just
i don't know you know we're kind of it
kind of just threw us through a loop
because
we had a crazy 2020 and we were like you
know what we're going to be settled we
know we're going to be it's our first
home
got this nine month old and we're out of
the state but now we get this thrown at
us we're like okay
we just really want to think with
objective opinions and just
what's the best decision to go forth on
this yeah
so is the um the property in a
floodplain
you know it's in a low risk area and
it's never
really had anything happened to it
before it really surprised everyone and
our realtor is getting more information
and you know there's
there's a federal flood plain
right is it in a flood plain
it's technically not it's a 3 out of 10
score on the fema risk that's the best
information that i could find
and our realtor said no it's not and she
seems to think that they've been doing
some paving
and like re-doing of the roads in that
neighborhood and it may have changed the
flow of water and it could have just
been this freak thing
that happened to this home and like one
or two others but
we just don't know whether it's a freak
thing or not you know
now it's on the history of this has been
flooded
and you know we wonder if it's even
worth staying in or maybe it's just a
free thing and it's an opportunity we
just don't know you are brand new
married you have a nine month old and
it's your very first home purchase you
don't need this
absolutely not right
i'm getting out of it man
right now you said i think it's just
that it's just a house deal yeah
it is just a house deal and the house
flooded yeah and they lost their buyer
that's it now you said you may lose some
money what money will you lose
well it's not much so like what we you
know they didn't have a radon system
installed and we talked with the seller
and said hey you know if we
you know end up going to this home we
love that a radon system installed they
said sure
you know we decided to pay that up they
were going to give us a credit at
closing
which is about 2 200 and um
the rate on system is only 1600 and we
said yeah we'd pay for that
you know now then we get that money back
at closing
we're just you know wondering would we
have to eat that cost and yeah you're
right you'll have to eat that coffee
you lost that money yeah and the lesson
you learn is you don't put
you don't put systems in other people's
houses
right you know you shouldn't have done
it that way they should have done it
period
if they wanted to do the deal got it but
um okay
if you wanted it that bad but um yeah
that's your lesson
here but you know they they've got a
flooded house with a new radon system in
it bless their hearts
you know yeah that's uh it's just a hot
crazy market
it doesn't it doesn't matter yeah it
doesn't matter your life is already
crazy
you're moving you have a nine month old
and a new marriage
the last thing you need is a flooded
basement man absolutely man yeah that's
a week
that was kind of my instinct i just kind
of needed to hear that objective
five years five years from today you'll
be glad you did not insert this hassle
and mess and clean up and potential
future problems
into your life while you have all these
other things on your plate that are much
more important
right even if you rent for a year
whoopty doopty
right right yeah we just because they
were saying you know maybe we'll lower
the cost like significantly and now
it's not about the cost it's about it's
about you're right you give up a huge
chunk of your life
in an already chaotic life it's about
peace man yeah
you want peace right you need peace yeah
right now
if you call me up and said i want to
build a house yeah
i would tell you don't build a house for
your first home don't build a house in
your first year of marriage and don't
build a house with a nine-month-old
this is a good way to get a divorce you
know
but why it's peace it doesn't it doesn't
mean building a house is a bad idea
it means in your situation you are
asking for crap
you're asking for trouble man and just
don't do that
i wouldn't do it yeah andrew i would
just call you real to say hey let's get
out of the deal
asap yeah just end it man i'm sorry and
start fresh and
go look for something that's not in a
flood plain